no labor day i think a lot of people
have the day off
many of you probably spent the day with
your families doing something fun
i had the day off as well on labor day
but instead of spending it with my
family
i spent it with my two best friends max
weinberg and our announcer
joel goddard i just did i i love these
guys you're the best
oh thanks it was a good time
and uh we had a barbecue that's what we
did like a lot of people do on labor day
we had a barbecue and we took a lot of
pictures
and i went to the photo hut like half an
hour before the show
uh was aired and i got the pictures back
and uh i thought instead of just hogging
these all to myself what if i shared
them with you
in a little piece i'm going to call
labor day backyard barbecue
photos
these are great these are fun remember i
guess we had a good time you me and joel
all right well first uh
joel uh hosted the event in the space
behind his apartment building um
and uh he was really raring to go he was
excited and i showed up first
i was really uh yeah that's how i make
the scene folks
the big thumbs up and i arrived and joel
said
it's conan
i instantly wished i had gone to a
different party
then max arrived and it was good to see
max and we stood way too close to each
other
and joel said with max weinberg and the
max weinberg seven
max then whispered to me can you believe
this [ __ ]
and i said i know this party is gonna
stink
joel then said what are you guys talking
about
i lied and said it's great to be with my
best friends
joel then said we are best friends
aren't we
i knew it was going to be a long day so
i decided to chug a beer
we had a good time there good yeah yeah
yeah i can unhinge my jaw like a snake
that too here i am
budweiser's a sponsor right jeff oh what
a coincidence all right uh
so i was drinking the beer max asked if
joel had any of the harder stuff
so joel gave him a bottle of mezcal
joel then reminded max to be careful and
not eat
the worm but max fished it out and said
eating the worm doesn't do anything
that's just a myth so max ate the worm
and started to hallucinate
first he started screaming at me
because she thought i was a giant bat
[Applause]
look at the hair on that back
[Applause]
i love that you think i'm a bat but my
hair is still miraculously intact
anyway that's our christmas card i've
decided right there
anyway max got so freaked out he smashed
his head into
into a wall and then passed out in the
corner
joel then pointed to his pool and said
wanna go for a swim
i said uh sorry joel i don't have a
swimsuit
joel said well i do
that bat's starting to look pretty good
huh
i said that g joel could that thing be
any
tighter and joel said
if i pull it over my shoulders it can
hey jeff want to check in with that
dayton affiliate see how they're
enjoying their new late night show
anyway joel said if i pull it over my
shoulders it can
[Applause]
joel i can't do this next one
but i must for i am paid
joel then proceeded to parade around the
deck for a while
[Music]
just enjoying the view there
anyway uh seeing that kind of made me
don't show it again alan
don't show it take it away
anyway seeing that photo made me feel
sick uh
so wait there's our christmas card
anyway max then came to and said let's
barbecue
joel said you hold the burgers while i
get the grill
max said how can you grill on a garbage
can
joel said put the beef on the lid take
out a spray can and a cigarette lighter
and cook it
[Applause]
well both max and the meat got pretty
badly burned
and i gotta say it tasted really awful
it was just terrible
so i washed the taste out of my mouth
with a beer and another one
then a full six-pack
[Applause]
and i got to tell you i started feeling
pretty good right around that time
yeah that's give you
tribute to my people
then i heard someone coming huh
that's the face i make when i'm startled
it was britney spears and her fiance
kevin federline
i said what are you two doing in new
york
kevin federline said you make a lot of
jokes about us and we want you to stop
he wouldn't look at me for some reason
only one photo was available uh i said
okay i'll stop then i said oh and if you
guys need a place to stay while you're
out here this thing's perfect for
white trash
kevin federline then punched me in the
face
and brittany kicked max in the groin
joel saved the day though by rushing in
and tying them both up with his speedo
it was quick thinking on joel's part
and it was the greatest labor day ever
isn't that nice
[Music]
all right folks we're gonna take a
little break stick around when we come
back
matthew broderick